All the warning signs were there - but they
were ignored for decades.
The alarm bells really went off this year–
hopefully not too late!
The Colorado River – the direct lifeline
for more than 42 million people, and indirectly
for tens of millions more is in peril.
“It's really bad right now and it's only
supposed to get worse next year.
You know, the fundamental aspect to this,
though, is that we experts, and decision makers,
we've known for decades that there's this
challenge on the Colorado River.
We've known that we take more water out of
the system and the river can actually supply,
but we've known that.”
” In the west of the United States water
is the new gold, the most sought-after commodity.
For the states of Utah and Wyoming, for Arizona,
California, for Nevada, New Mexico, and Colorado
water has become a huge problem.
The same goes for dozens of native American
tribes and communities of indigenous people.
All face harsh water cutbacks and tremendous
challenges in the future.
Things are so bad- the federal government
had to step in.
Washington DC - The Department of Interior
and its’ Federal Bureau of Reclamation.
In an audio only-press conference – a sound
assessment of what is now slugged a drought
or water crisis and of what has become a top
priority for the White House.
“The prolonged drought afflicting the West
is one of the most significant challenges
facing our communities in our country.
Right now, almost 93% of the western United
States is experiencing drought, or abnormally
dry conditions, with more than 70% of the
western United States experiencing severe
or extreme drought conditions.”
Those “prolonged” drought conditions manifest
even in the Rocky Mountains.
Global warming and climate change make for
very mild winters that don’t produce enough
snow melt anymore for the Colorado River to
carry downstream into Lake Powell, Lake Mead
and beyond.
“The Colorado River Basin is in its 23rd
year of a historic drought.
Both Lake Powell and Lake Mead the two largest
reservoirs in the United States are at historically
low levels with combined storage of 28% of
their capacity.
The system is approaching a tipping point.
And without action, we cannot protect the
system for the millions of Americans who rely
on this critical resource.”
We’re meeting with Christian Gerlach, a
community activist and senior representative
of national environmental organization the
“Sierra Club”.
Christian wants to show us a place called
Echo Bay within what is known as Lake Mead
National Recreational Area – just a few
miles east of Las Vegas.
“Hardly anybody ever comes to Echo Bay unfortunately.
It was very popular spot, so popular in fact
it had an airport, but as you can see the
water levels dropped so dramatically, it’s
effected the economy of the area.
There are not people coming out to visit and
to recreate as much here in Echo Bay.”
Echo Bay is not the only spot falling victim
to unprecedented and record low water levels
of Lake Mead.
From where the water stood in 2008, Mead visitors
now must drive almost 1093 yards, or a kilometer
more, until they can launch their boats.
Besides, there’s the only one boat ramp
left open.
Years ago, there were 12.
The Marina, once a bustling hot spot for boaters
and water sport enthusiasts has more mostly
empty parking space now than ever before.
At Lake Mead - created by the Hoover Dam,
- one can see and experience what it means
when experts say “the system is at a tipping
point”.
“I’d be concerned.
Seems lower than average and global warming
has something going on with it.”
Christina Taub - a flight attendant from Germany
- also visits Hoover Dam, she is alarmed by
what she observed.
“I think the bell should have rung a long
time ago and it should keep ringing.
Something has to be done about it.
It is very dangerously low.
And we’re actually
part of a flight crew and we flew over a few
days ago and just to see it also from above
at 40,000 feet – I can show you pictures,
it’s unbelievable!”
Mead’s water level shrank by a whopping
150-plus feet in the last 40 years.
An ever-growing so-called white bathtub ring
here and at other reservoirs will have devastating
effects for all US states in the lower Colorado
River Basin, for tens of millions of people
and hundreds of thousands of businesses in
Nevada, Arizona, California and even in Mexico.
“The impacts we're seeing from climate change
are I think, you know, most of what we are
more are happening quicker than we would have
expected.
And things the impacts of snowpack translating
into flows in the river are being impacted
by climate change things like soil moisture,
temperatures, evapo-transpiration, all these
little mechanisms, all these little components
to the hydrologic cycle.
Here in the West, are being squeezed by climate
change.”
“We are on track to see additional drops
in the water levels, to the point where it’s
scary.
We may face what is called “dead pool”,
where water will not even flow out of Lake
Mead further down the Colorado River system.”
No shortage of water in so-called Sin City.
The expansive water fountain display in front
of Las Vegas’ iconic Hotel Bellagio is just
one example.
What a waste?
Not so fast!
Las Vegas, boom town and self-declared entertainment
capital of the world is in fact top of the
line when it comes to water recycling, preservation
and conservation.
“So, places like Las Vegas, have actually
done amazing efforts in terms of water conservation.
If every city that relied on Colorado River
water would do as Las Vegas has done, our
cities would be in a much better spot.
Las Vegas has really been a leader when it
comes to water conservation.
So, things like the pools you're looking at,
like the big fountains in front of Bellagio
that's recycled water that's not potable water.”
In Las Vegas pictures like this- sprinklers
irrigating golf courses or public parks - won’t
make for a lot of fuss.
All water used is recycled, re-used over and
over again.
In the cities suburbs homeowners rip out the
grass in their front and back yards and replace
it with gravel or fake grass.
Throughout the city so called “no-functional
turf grass” is banned now.
Most areas of turf that require a lot of irrigation
have been replaced.
“The Southern Nevada Water Authority has
taken tremendous steps toward reducing the
water usage.
In the past 20 years, the state of Nevada
has seen tremendous growth in the Las Vegas
Valley.
But we've actually seen a decrease in our
water usage.
Thanks to programs that help people take out
their water thirsty lawns.”
That’s good news of course and those measures
are critically important.
However, they won’t make a difference big
enough to create change on a larger scale
needed to prevent even worse drought and water
conditions in the future.
“We do need to make hard cuts that that's
the fundamental solution on the Colorado River
is we have to use less water and you know
the scale of how much we need to use less
is millions of acre feet.
So, you know, the Colorado River on average,
in the last 20 years, it's applied like 13-to-14-million-acre
feet per year 13 to 14 million acre feet.
You know, the Bureau of Reclamation who manages
the system is telling us we need to cut 2-to-4-million-acre
feet.
So that's like 15 to 30% of how much water
we use on economy needs to be cut immediately.
So that's a lot of water.
That's a big scale.”
Experts warn that Only unprecedented big scale
water use reductions, strict water conservation,
and ultimately the de-carbonization of our
economies – will secure the Colorado River
as a life source for tens of millions of people
and for hundreds of thousands of businesses.
“We got to decarbonize our economies, we've
got to address the situation of the carbon
cycle which is intricately linked to the natural
water cycle.
There is tremendous amounts more carbon in
the atmosphere than there was several decades
ago.
And that trend continues on and as we see
that we will see additional heat waves we
will see this additional heat urban island
effect in suburban areas where we do have
more asphalt when it rains, especially here
in Las Vegas.
A lot of asphalt funnels the water towards
Lake Mead, but a lot of it is lost due to
evaporation it no longer penetrates the water
table.
So, it's all an interconnected system.
And we've got to take a look at our developed
society is currently operating to make those
changes.”
Making those - perhaps painful but strongly
needed changes is not a can-do any longer,
but a must-do, experts say.
Otherwise the mighty Colorado River is feared
to become not much more than a trickle – rather
sooner than later.